well thanks everyone so I'm from
Michigan
which in case you've never been is a
garbage States in the Midwest I could
summarize 22 years of experience in
Michigan with one story I was at a
Chinese food restaurant as a kid and I
overheard the woman at the table next to
us say to the waiter what kind of
Chinese restaurant doesn't have ranch
dressing
I just never go there I've been seeing
the same therapist for three years and I
recently decided to make small talk
before our most recent session and I
asked him what neighborhood in LA he
lives in and he told me quote I don't
feel comfortable telling you that well
that's the new lowest point of my entire
life perhaps the man who knows me best
in the world thinks I'm such a frothing
lunatic I can't be trusted with vague
geographic information if I've admitted
to you that my first wet dream was to
Bob Vila at least you could say is
downtown
[Applause]
I'll tell you this the last two weeks of
my heterosexuality right before I came
out of the closet I just convinced
myself I was just really attracted to
female bodybuilders
which is adorable um also a bit of a
tough sell cuz that would always be it
like over at my friends places for
sleepovers and they will be looking at
pictures of Britney Spears and they'd be
like oh my god she's so hot and I was
always like yeah right you've never even
seen Carole Szymanski the Latvian
gladiator and they'd be like whoo and
then I would pull up a picture of just
this beast like eating a fence
she was always eating stuff and I was
like she's perfect
actually had a date a couple weeks ago
and is but it's been like very hot in LA
um so I put on like my best pair of
shorts and like my favorite t-shirt I
was like oh my god as I was leaving my
building I saw my neighbor and he was
like have a good run
[Applause]
and you just watched me sprint to my car
I did I did though I met my favorite
homophobe in the world in Michigan
though his name was Fred Phelps he was
the minister of the Westboro Baptist
Church which is most famous for being
super anti-gay and they go around the
country protesting funerals and all this
stuff but I thought he was amazing
because he came to my University senior
year and he protested my entire
university because and I'm not making
this up
Elton John had been there once that was
the whole reason why he came so I went
to the counter protest and I got a
little bored during it so I started
calling Fred Phelps
a gaywad to his a face consuming that
was gonna get a rise out of Fred Phelps
and like three or four iterations in he
actually dropped his sign he looked me
dead in the eyes and he said I'm not the
gaywad gaywad greatest comeback of all
time
it was it was so good that my dad who
was next to me actually leaned in and
said he's got you there that's my time
thanks everyone
great job fantastic thank you good luck
everybody
you